be in the malaysian miss miss malaysia
did you see what she wrote no so she
wrote this whole Instagram story post
where she says basically it is the
racism in America it is what it is if
you just need to get this she goes if
you're a colored person in America you
shouldn't complain because you chose it
what she says you chose to be a colored
person in America so why complain let me
read that to you it's not what she said
do you David do you have any bleach I
made the wrong choice I need to change
back so this is what she wrote Samantha
Katie by the way okay to the black
people oh my god it really says that
shit's tight washes this girl she's she
spit hot fire I hope y'all are sitting
down to the black people relax take it
as a challenge it makes you stronger
it makes you stronger this is a
Malaysian pageant winner by the way
because you know she's with the people
samantha katie is her name or also as i
like to call her [__] back
you chose to be born as a colored person
in america for a reason to learn a
certain lesson accept it as it is till
now hunger and poverty still exists it
is what it is it's inevitable best you
can do is remain calm protect heart and
don't allow it to crumble that's your
responsibility of course this is to the
ones who understand this level and state
of mind it's not for everyone everyone
grows at a different rate that's her
whole state she was hacked what she had
this is her [__] I'm trying to I'm
trying to help I'm trying to help her
out I
- speechless the black people already
[__] up I love what she says that it's
a lesson that we're supposed to learn
but she wants us to learn that lesson
and just sit there and take it like wow
I really learned my lesson don't
evangelize it don't I mean there's a lot
that I could take from it but there's so
much of that they're so ridiculous hard
to understand there's there's no
response it's almost like you you ever
use like one of those random randomly
generated things if you think she used
one that was like use the most offensive
things possible in a current in a
current event and go and she's like this
looks great I'm gonna post this that is
you know above all it's it's amazing to
me that she genuinely thought that that
would work that would work oh sure can I
just read her apology though she has an
apology no the best I don't yes yes I do
hear you I'm sorry I know you're hurting
I know it's unfair I'm not in your shoes
to understand this fully then you should
probably shut the [__] up and
furthermore you asked me to explain what
I meant by black people chose to be
black Oh God is that throughout my
journey I have learned that we are more
than just temporary physical body like
an avatar merely a tiny speck of dust in
the vast infinite universe are you Neil
deGrasse Tyson you [__] dumb ho what
the [__] are you saying right now we are
about to mere speck of dust in the
cosmos that came out the dingleberry out
of my ass talent show segment for when
she won was just like mr. Roboto or
something just her [__] space galaxy
music just exactly we tend to overlook
that from time to time in our process
towards evolution as a human being on
earth we you sound like an alien [__]
robot we chose our body our family [__]
you know what this you know it she's
basically saying on this she's saying
that black is not a race it's a way that
you're acting and you chose to act that
way which is literally the most racist
[__] I've ever heard of my life just
like I've literally been called the
n-word to my face and that that is
more racist no but you chose to be that
that's right that's it and sit down
because it is what it is
Blackey anger anger translator we need
girl honestly I've been called Blacky by
a white girl before and to this day I
think that's the most offensive thing
like I've ever been wait I think so
Lackey
Blacky like like like a cute little
nickname like ie a peon that's so funny
yo Michael che had to stand up where he
was he was talking about he goes like I
don't understand why [__] transsexual
people are so upset by me calling them
[__] [__]
white a homegirl that was a transsexual
woman she comes up and she goes she goes
well how would you like it if I called
you Blacky he goes a good point what it
is about that wire that ie at the end
but uh that's pretty bad she goes we
chose our body our family our place of
birth our name in our lessons from the
path we take tailor-made for us [__]
that's so not even facts it's unreal you
don't choose your [__] body that's
you get what you get [__] she acts like
when the sperm hit the [__] ovary
this [__] had a conversation
with the ovaries like hey you want me
black Asian why to what pierce my
[__] head inside you what we gonna be
David you know maybe maybe she as the
enlightened one as maybe we forgot about
a collective memory that she still
retains where upon birth she was select
she was allowed to select her race there
were all these colors and she said I
just want if she honestly if she wrote
that [__] I'd understand she goes when I
came into the universe as a speck of
dust I remember I remember when I saw
the ovary I chose my ethnicity I said oh
this [__] is crazy
now I understand dude that looks fallout
it OS or more yes I understand a lot of
people have shared that I could have
phrased my content differently and I
accept that I am responsible for my
words I will make sure I try to
articulate my speech in a proper manner
kneel on the platform you don't know how
to this just so
[__] bad so let me continue this real
quick mm-hmm to clear the air yes I did
poorly finally never again yes I did
poorly articulate myself when writing
black people chose to be black and to
the black people relax and take it as a
challenge that makes you stronger no
[__]
if I had been more attentive in how I
wrote it no that's not it
the message would have been understood
no it wouldn't have as a heartfelt
message to all victims no it's not of
racism be it of any color yes my mother
is Chinese Malaysian father is Brazilian
and my foster parents who raised me up
are Indian Malaysian she's obviously a
minority and I think that when she won
two people felt like she represented
this minority yeah do you think that
because this is a thing sometimes do you
think that she's trying to distance
herself from that culture and not be a
minority and be closer to white culture
I think a lot of people don't understand
this when they when they're [__]
sitting up at their ivory tower when
they used to be in the slums they forget
what it was like yes right they set up
in their [__] ivory tower and they
look down on people and they feel like I
earned this I deserved this I worked for
it and none of you works for it and they
go oh oh I could see why they they used
to treat me like this is because they
didn't have money and they were savages
and I'm not a savage anymore I'm not a
little [__] Savage it's [__]
ridiculous listen I understand that to
the minimal amount of sense of where
like sometimes with me like I'll go back
home Sacramento right not like this but
I'm saying like it when I go to the hood
I because I'm in the hood anymore I get
a little scared yeah because I look like
a little [__] now okay I don't know how
to like you know I'm saying I don't know
how to act anymore like what's up I'm
like forget sometimes you know I mean I
forget where I came from it's like hold
on a second you want that [__] but I
was on that block [__] [__] out of you
so I forget sometimes where I come from
too in that sense
but not yes yes this is not at all not
at all and like when we when we like we
dude I was in I can't even where I was
just five years ago like I can't believe
where I am now and I'm so [__] happy
but my thought process and that is not
to turn my back on that it's to try to
lend a helping hand like do whatever
okay like [__] one of the things that
I've been really big on is that with all
this stuff going on black lives matter I
feel like we forgot about the a lot of
effects of kovat that have happened yeah
and something that really upset me was
just the other day I was posting about
this [__] Beverly Hills in Santa Monica
had decided to curfew at 1:00 p.m.
their restaurants were closing
restaurants had to close at 6:00 like
every look the pot shop was closed the
whole world was shutting down David I
was panicking [__] but but my thought on
that was like delivery restaurants
everything was shut down David have you
ever had a time where rent was do you
know that you got a grace period and
you're like [__] alright it's the 30th
maybe you were depressed last week and
you're like alright I'm gonna grind it
out for these next six days and I'm
gonna pay rent now imagine the whole
world shows last week that was literally
last week I don't know what you're
talking about I still got some hood ass
tendencies when I got a bill to pay and
like they gonna give me a five great
five day grace period i'ma hold on as
money as long as possible imagine you
have to go and make it and I'm yeah I've
done that